[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
je ne vous donne pas tout le maire parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de sujets on va parler
évidemment des morts qui ont marqué la
semaine johnny hallyday jean d'ormesson
a parlé aussi de la corse
on va parler d'histoire et pour en
parler
fink colophane berger bonjour vous êtes
merde plaisir vice-présidente de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines des vice
présidente du conseil départemental
c'est à dire que vous avez des journées
occupé dire ça comme ça alors que tu es
devant baptiste duclair qui est maître
de conférences à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin savoir patrice
ça va très bien est ce que un peu
fatigué travail cette semaine
mon service est plutôt second semestre
[Rires]
mais la recherche a été vraiment prolixe
c'était va de mon sens bonjour je pense
à l'université de versailles saint
quentin
tout va bien universitaire fatigué c'est
un oxymore toujours en éveil
toujours en éveil c'est comme les
éditeurs bonjour très bien alors deux
derniers opus de votre maison d'édition
un charmant petit village roman policier
de jean michel lecocq je le montre comme
ça certainement pas c'est absolument
c'est un dîner sincèrement petit village
dans le haut var magnifique s'appelle
villecroze moi honnêtement je connais
pas mais tous les gens qui voient ce
livre diabeo connaître je prends bien
puis par un village avec des habitations
troglodytes fin dans le haut var
magnifique et bien évidemment mais il
s'y passe quelques quelques meurtres
c'est une histoire de vengeance
très très amusante pas à gore du tout on
n'est plus écouté agatha christie
presque ya un côté d eux sens le plus
sympathique du terme se faire qu on
n'est pas dans le nez pas dans les
ventres mans l'éviscération temps on est
dans nos coeurs c'est chic distinguer
agréable tech3 pour sal
voilà avec un beau duo d'un beau duo
d'enquêteurs 13 groupes pro vente
j'hésite à jolimont ya jean baptiste qui
est un peu du coin aussi
oui c'est vrai plus c'est pas assez vite
crowley non pas du tout non justement le
garde comme ça jusqu'à la fin de
l'émission verra tout à l'heure vous
voulez peut-être un peu de portraits
d'enfants sont comme ça n'a jamais eu
jusqu'à présent et l'on voit voilà une
personne n'en parle
il faut rétablir cet avis cette
injustice alors on va écouter un petit
peu comme ça en chansons telles que 61
et nikki retraçant sa carrière
[Musique]
dans le matin et noir se noie
il n'y a
il est
tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
vous l'avez vu il ya 4,6 à ya deux ans
j'avoue que je suis restée scotchée
parce que c'était pas du tout quelque
chose que j'ai compris je connaissais
comme ça je vois pas exagérer je vais
pas jouer la snob mais c'est vrai que
c'était pas trop ma tasse de thé
et j'avoue que je suis resté vraiment
impressionné c'est une bête de scène
j'étais pas si près que ça mais quand il
arrive sur scène on voit les convoyer
que lui pourtant les troncs et j'aime
beaucoup eddy mitchell surtout d'être au
prend la lumière et 30 où je suis resté
très ému parce que je me suis dit mais
comment j'ai pu passer à côté de ça
pendant dix ans je m'en suis voulu
gratter voit la france est alors c'est
vrai que tous les médias en font
énormément de les journaux des des
numéros spéciaux il ira spéciale du
point et ils vont faire de numéros des
ya un numéro donné à l'idée un numéro un
jean d'ormesson
c'est parce qu'ils avaient prévu c'est
un troisième numéro 10 en une autre on
aura enfin quelques informations là
depuis quelques jours des trous ça te
dit quelque chose quand même 7 cette
sorte d'unanimité ce sont deux morts
très différents a priori très
différentes
un académicien plutôt n'est aristocrates
et un homme du peuple de l'autre côté un
conservateur et éclairé quelqu'un
rockeur donc plus tôt
voilà quelques km couru un peu dans les
brancards c'est une personne de droite
alors voilà l'idée de droits cette sorte
d'unanimité sait pas qu'il ya au fond
derrière ces hommages belot et loup
derrière de l'académicien était jean
d'ormesson et et du rockeur qui était
donnée n'est une besoin de ceux de se
réunir de s'unir de de se dire tiens
voilà c'était peut-être quelque chose
qui était france et une identité
française derrière laquelle on court
mais je pense que ni l'un ni l'autre
n'étaient dans la mièvrerie nez et dans
la dans la pensée unique
donc ça c'est déjà c'était très agréable
à d'ormesson bien évidemment enfin je
veux dire d'ormesson il est quand même
beaucoup plus connu est beaucoup plus
appréciés ils étaient beaucoup plus
apprécié pour ses interviews pour ce
qu'ils pouvaient raconter pour sa balise
pour son regard ses deux tonnes de
choses que véritablement pour ce qu'il a
écrit parce que je défie beaucoup de
gens qui sont en train de nous dire tout
le bien qu'ils pensent de d'ormesson de
lui citer un seul de ses livres ou de
nous dire de quoi ça parle
donc c'est un c'est un romancier un
écrivain c'est derrière moi je les
landes les élus j'ai beaucoup aimé
monsieur diallo la majorité des gens qui
encensent maintenant d'ormesson sont des
gens qui sont séduits parce que il le
voyait chez avec bernard pivot et le
voyait à tel endroit
ces sagouins côté andré grasset plus la
personnalité que l'écrivain que les gens
regrette pour mes beaux tableaux y
mettait tout pour de nos jours qu'elle
regrette on pas le mur n'est en effet
ses livres dans lesquels il y avait
d'ailleurs laissé ski d'été
même dans l'est libyen vers une sorte
d'art de la conversation il y avait un
esprit français
je pense que c'était l'eau des derniers
représentants peut-être c'est pas une
aura d'autres après mais parce qu'on
appelait l'esprit foncé dans un esprit
libre aussi parce que libre je crois
parce que véritablement il avait il
était capable de dire vraiment ce qu'il
pensait en dehors de la littérature il
s'immisçait dans le monde politique je
le parlais avec les plus grands il avait
il avait ce don de la sympathie aux
autres qui est quand même assez
extraordinaire
et puis pour re juste par rapport à
johnny hallyday je crois qu'on a on a
very un paradoxe là mais ça représente
quand même notre société on a aussi très
caricatural ce que je dis mais en même
temps chacun y trouve son compte avec
les deux ça me fait penser mais il sait
pas moi qui l'ait dit mais piaf et
cocteau on a eu aussi 7,7
la pièce fait quand on a fait le
rapprochement parce qu'ils sont morts le
même jour et que la mort de piaf
totalement occulté celle de celle des
cocteau c'est un peu ce qui s'est passé
pour jean d'ormesson même si même si je
sais pas s'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
aimait forcément leurs ailes ou mais on
ne veut pas passer totalement une part
sociale de 5 de gens d'en bas se
trouvaient les gens mais il avait aussi
ce site de de très remarquable c'est que
c'est vrai que johnny
c'est vraiment une map personnage inter
générationnel qui transcende les milieux
sociaux etc
je pense qu'il est à trouver ses fans ou
ceux qui l'apprécient un peu partout
dans la société et l'exil fiscal que
tout le monde adore ça j'ai pas oublier
enfin parvenue alors je crois que sa vie
à gstaad a été un enfer oui il a tenté
de venir de devenir belge pour passer
outre le traité entre la france et
monaco pour pouvoir devenir monégasque
ensuite ça n'a pas fonctionné
mais oui on serait prêt à lui pardonner
finalement est alors d'ormesson et de là
à dire qu'il était apprécié de manière
très générationnel c'est peut-être et
dans tout dans tous les milieux de la
société peu tassé d'état je crois qu'il
ya plusieurs étapes c'est réglé une
étape gros le milieu intello le
considéré comme ringard et puis après la
probablement après le mariage avec
nathalie baye a failli et le ton de
tournage avec godard il a été il est
redevenu quelqu'un avec qui je pense est
content allez tout temps mais sans
jamais atteindre non mais bien sûr non
je parlais de d'enlever son pardon ne
m'a pas prévenu lors d'un soir dans une
salle
bref mais c'est moi non mais je vous en
prie je vous en prie et donc mais
d'ormesson me plaisait aussi parce que
alors cessé bouquin était assez
finalement assez assez assez facile à
lire en fin de contrat il y avait un peu
de un peu de salles reste philo
c'est un peu la fina a expliqué à mes
enfants je trouvais que c'était assez
assez ça mais c'est assez dire fait avec
cette tare comme ça la culture la
conversation la conversation et raison
d'une espèce de gentilhomme doit
traverser les époques alors johnny la
conversation un peu moins sans doute
mais dansez dansez dansez dans ses
interprétations il était il était très
fort j'avais des aphorismes drôle tous
ces hommages c'est par exemple france
inter le matin de la mort de johnny
hallyday a consacré et deux heures
à son éloge et c'est alors que ça
l'hiver ça fait à peu près dix ans qu'il
n'y a pas une chanson géniale idée sur
france inter donc c'est sécurisé de ces
d'avoir récupéré je crois que ça a
expliqué un moment quand il a ce qu'on
appelait la nouvelle chanson française
avec de l'herbe etc
il a été blacklisté pratiques et là tout
d'un coup ils ont récupéré avec une
facilité socialiste ça c'est assez drôle
c'est justement la preuve qu'il
appartient à tout le monde
jean baptiste oui bon on parler de
l'esprit français
alors ce qui parce qu'on dit ils
appartiennent à la france mais se pose
de savoir qu'est ce qu'est la france
tels qu'ils sont et de savoir si l'un va
avec ce qu'on pense de la patrie de la
france mais c'est vrai que chez enfin
tout cacher chez johnny hallyday je
pense qu'il va vraiment dans cette idée
de deux passions françaises qui veut
qu'on a toujours des forces
contradictoires qui se réunissent et
dans ce personnage ce qui est assez
saisissant c'est que sur scène c'est un
homme qui est complètement exubérant qui
est une fureur de vivre qui donne tout
alors que lorsqu'ils quittent la scène
il se cache derrière sa cigarette il
extrêmement pudique timide et il ya
vraiment ce double visage de cet homme
qui donne cette cette richesse
qui fait que nolan pour tous qu'il est
une forme de double caricature qu'il
assume complètement
alors que charles et jean d'ormesson
c'est plutôt une forme de contradiction
quitte à assumer puisque cette offre un
homme de droite qu'ils annoncent
clairement et qui en même temps est tout
à fait dans la nuance qui est capable
d'entendre d'écouté 2 qui qui qui
vraiment sur lui sur même sur les grands
enjeux de société des enjeux sociaux et
séraphin apprend beaucoup cetera est
capable de se positionner là beaucoup
d'hommes de droite préféré rester un
petit peu dans une forme de doxa qui dit
à leur histoire
et donc voilà un homme de seuil à l'aise
il ya ce symbole comme mitterrand et
quand quitte le pouvoir c'est avec
converser avec des hommes qui
appartiennent à tout le monde parce
qu'ils ont des contradictions surmonter
assume et c'est enfin jeu assez
fascinant de voir qu'ils partent en même
temps s'il n'y avait pas et que
finalement même si johnny hallyday une
fin un charisme et une légende qui
beaucoup plus importante n'efface pas
complètement l'autre non plus n'ont pas
tout à fait peut-être que peut-être que
pierre cocteau va avec
alors pour le coup la mort de cocteau
m'était totalement occulté la même dit à
un moment que il était mort parce qu'ils
avaient de la peine
oui régis harry lapp et quelques bières
et jean barrère et de démentis démenti
cette information
il ya aussi une chose qui est assez
intéressante je sais pas c'est une
hypothèse mais on n'a pas l'impression
par exemple il va y avoir une
manifestation très populaire pour le
long terme enfin de donner à l'idée
voilà ça me dit on à pas on a
l'impression que aux foules et les
décideurs
c'est pas eux qui décident de ça ils
suivent un peu le mouvement
l'impression est un mouvement
impopulaire comme ça et que on s'adapte
à cette volonté d'en faire qu'on va voir
en fait si les médias n'ont pas un peu
sur réagit suivant l'affluence qui aura
ou pas ou long des champs-elysées
s'il ya effectivement une foule de 500
mille personnes 600 mille personnes qui
sont la faim énormément de monde
ok merveilleux sinon on se dira pas
peut-être que pendant trois jours 24
heures sur 24 on a peut-être fait
beaucoup mais voilà oui c'est
intéressant je n'établis sillage
oui c'est vrai que c'est vrai que c'est
on a l'impression
oui il ya un mouvement de foule et vient
entre n est pas seulement tout le temps
à toutes les manifestations qui va y
avoir derrière ça s'emballe on est un
peu dans une société où les choses
fortes qui se passe et qui touche au
niveau de l'humain que ce soit dans le
dramatique comme ça on peut pas dire que
c'est pas du dramatique c'est je veux
dire à aller dans une danse la vie mais
on a l'impression que la société réagi
beaucoup plus vite que ça ne l'a été à
une époque que ce soit dans les gars
tiff ou dans je dirais l'exaltation et
du coup il ya un mouvement
deux papes l'on va dire qui est ce un
d'ailleurs parce que c'est agréable de
voir cet engouement là et ça suit
derrière
à tel point que macro va faire un disque
sauf qu'ici ce sera un petit peu là vers
ce sont quand même les médias qui ont
démarré les premiers ils ont démarré à 7
heures du matin ou à 6 heures du matin
avant même que le l'opinion publique ne
soit quasiment au courant donc
normalement celle inverse que je
rappelle quand même pour le fukushima la
catastrophe de fukushima
france 2 et tf1 n'avait même pas casser
l'antenne il s'est rien passé jusqu'à 13
heures sur tf1 et sur france 2 mondes
fukushima alors que la 17 heures du
matin c'était fini même sur tf1 ils ont
enlevé les yeux ils ont tout enlever
s'est passé c'est donc c'est plat ce
sont des médias qui ont pris 2 le
phénomène parce qu'ils ont senti à 6h du
matin parce que c'est parce qu'ils ont
senti de la fin c'était un peu oui
c'était d'abord d'abord c'était quelque
chose
information 1 magasin qui est passé
l'après-midi à tf1 qui a fait un peu
irrité les poils de téléspectateurs mais
je suis pas sûr que ce soit les médias
qui gouvernent là et je pense qu'ils
essayent de prendre le pouls de la
population après ils ont tort ils ont
raison c'est autre chose mais je pense
qu'il faut garder ce qui s'est passé pas
tout à fait comparable mais pour à
l'occasion du décès de simone veil par
exemple où cette panthéonisation très
spontanée à cette demande a conduit le
président de la république lui-même dire
oui enfin je crois qu'à les pentes enisa
blavec avec antoine veil c'était je
pensais en vous écoutant à à ce que à ce
qu'écrit un auteur que j'aime que j'aime
bien fin pierre rosanvallon kg
l'histoire de l'édition contemporaine au
collège de france et qui a écrit un
bouquin qui s'appelle le peuple
introuvable oui dit le peuple c'est un
concept qui est complètement abstrait
informe c'est un être froid etc
mais il ya quand même des petites des
petites séquences dans lesquelles
mondiale peuple émerger à paraître et et
je trouve que là on voit lancer début
une pâle peuple festif mais le peuple de
l'émotion en quelque sorte qui fait qui
fait valoir son existence c'est assez et
et des bas c'est beau c'est juste aimer
c'est pas de rennes et on le sent au
quotidien on le sou c'est sûr que si on
écoute la radio rien n'était les on est
complètement envahie par les images mais
malgré tout on le sent je dirais il ya
une communication entre les gens qui est
assez étonnante puisque ça devient
presque un fil rouge conducteur de
discussion dans la journée ça veut dire
qu'on est quand même très grégaire dans
nos dans nos ressentir et dans nos
émotions est donc plus ou moins il y en
a qui pleurent à marne la caq à la
conquête et puis y en a qui bien sûr qui
regarde ça avec un petit peu plus drôle
probablement si ce besoin d'avoir des
événements qui réunissent garder des
mini sentons très proches d'eric en tout
état de cause aérienne dramatique à
cette surmédiatisation voilà vers open
où on peut ne pas y souscrire totalement
bon je ne lis pas grave on n'est pas
obligé de regarder la télévision -
jean-charles n'inscrivaient pas non on
n'arriverait jamais bien j'aimais bien
sûr les dissuader le vois je l' ai vu
deux fois je construis pas j'ai pas de
disque de lui voilà après ces faits qui
m'ont fait c'était une star c'est le
phénomène
jean baptiste là dessus sur le nombre
sur le réserve pour la corse mais encore
jean d'ormesson mais que c'est vrai et
alors peut-être que si les
indépendantistes pour le pouvoir
n'aurait pas pu la voir parce que il
faudra de montils cinq ans de résidence
avons envie voir acheter on peut parler
si vous voulez delà de la corse puisque
c'est un sujet qui vous passionne donc
la victoire annoncée des
indépendantistes il ya un deuxième tour
mais a priori il ne devrait pas démentir
le premier avec un très fort score
alors oui la question c'est est ce qu'on
peut comparer ça ce qui se passe en
catalogne par exemple ce qui est un
phénomène catalan alors c'est assez
différent
je pense que c'est impossible mais c'est
différent non mais parce que les
catalans donc enfin veulent
l'indépendance immédiatement et donc
cherché à obtenir par tous moyens alors
qu'en corse
on a des nationalistes qui ne veulent
pas l'indépendance dans l'immédiat est
qui et qui la veulent pas pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord parce que
vraisemblablement les corses ne sont pas
enfin favorable majoritairement à
l'accession de la corse à l'indépendance
on voit notamment avec ce via un
mouvement donc nationalistes
indépendantistes qui a fait ces
élections qui a réuni seulement 6,9 pour
cent et qui lui réclamait indépendance
kiki qui donc on sent que les corses ne
sont pas encore prêts et jean guy
talamoni qui est le représentant
justement de cette formation plutôt
indépendantiste reconnaît lui-même que
ce n'est pas le moment la deuxième
raison c'est que pour accéder à dernier
pendant s'il faut que le territoire et
les moyens d'avoir cette indépendance
est économiquement
la corse n'est pas la catalogne
puisqu'elle n'a pas cette c'est original
que devient la richesse était donc c'est
un objectif qui qui qui à atteindre
aussi l'indépendance veut être acquise
pour que
voilà quelqu'un puisse réussir et puis
il est vrai aussi que la corse n'a pas
le même statut que la catalogne qui est
une communauté autonome et qu' une
certaine manière est beaucoup plus
proche de l'indépendance à une autonomie
qui est conquise qui est réelle
autonomie qui n'a pas qu'on a pas encore
et d'ailleurs le mouvement nationaliste
cherche dans un premier temps à obtenir
un statut qui à peu près comparable de
la communauté catalane a notamment sur
la fiscalité pouvoir fiscal pour les
cistes hâtif
enfin d'avoir une compétence accrue donc
la comparaison est intéressante mais on
peut pas non plus on voit la dire que
pour l'instant c'est la volonté
d'indépendance des mises en sourdine pas
même par ceux qui la souhaitent et qui
prennent juste le pouvoir puisqu'il a
été donnée mais est-ce que doudou venir
parce que au fond quand on regarde
l'histoire comme ça des des scrutins
corse les indépendantistes ou pas sont
rarement majoritaire
même alors le front national a fait 3 %
mais au deuxième tour des
présidentielles je crois que marine le
pen faisait quand même 48% sa conception
et fonderies n'ont pas pensé que des
indépendantistes qui votent pour le
front national nous semble-t-il mais
enfin en tout cas il faut quand même à
faire attention enfin on verra le
deuxième tour ce un corps sur deux plus
d'accord sur deux n'a pas voté
donc ça c'est que tout va être temps
donc toujours sérieux légitimement
penser que les autonomistes et des
indépendantistes sont quand même plus
motivés à aller voter que le que les
autres qui sont peu vont je m'en
foutiste ou voilà qu'ils vont tous on
verra bien enfin je pense qu'il ya
peut-être que dimanche on va travailler
c'est enfin pour en revenir à ce que
disait jean baptiste ce qui me choque
plus tôt face et ce qui m'interpelle
c'est problème de la langue c'est ce que
les
l'espagne a commis l'erreur de laisser
les catalans parler leur langue et voilà
on voit où ça mène
et que après si on laisse les corses
parlez-leur corse par les corses comme
comme ils ont essayé de le faire et
comme manuel valls avait très justement
lutter contre ça et je trouve que c'est
une bonne idée puisque c'est parti on
autorisera un boom un bout de la france
à parler une autre langue que le
français c'est fini c2c la balkanisation
du pays
c'est ce qui peut être inquiétant si ce
que vous évoquez c'est à dire que c'est
pas une volonté urgente de mettre les
joueurs en place
c'est avec d'autres voilà ce qui peut
paraître encore plus inquiétant parce
que justement est plus habile
voilà ils ont bien entre les mains et
ont connaissance leurs faiblesses et en
même temps certaines forces qu'il
peuvent avoir et donc 7 6 ça paraît pas
du tout comme un mouvement catalan qui
semble dans une ardeur avec une
historicité
oui tout à fait calculable alors là on
est sur autre chose et cette mise en
place peut être inquiétante comme a été
mis en place ce front national avec
cette lenteur et puis cet accompagnement
des autres les autres camps politiques
qui lui ont quand même permis de
s'installer un certain moment et c'est
ça qu'il faut faire attention je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut regarder ce que
vous évoquez sur la langue me semble
fondamental on a des choses en commun
que nous devons garder et la langue qu
une chose primordiale
moi je suis d'origine italienne et la
corse
quand je dis il ya des corps ce que nous
sommes proches puisque la langue
italienne
c'est quand même très propre média n'ont
simplement pas donc je veux dire c'est
même un rapprochement par rapport aux
racines italiennes c'est quelque chose
de complètement différent donc à
surveiller moi j'aurais tendance à dire
et il ya quand même aussi peut-être dans
le succès qu'ils ont peut-être une
faillite des partis traditionnels aussi
encore ce nom ils sont bien comportés
j'étais quand même très clanistes il y
avait pas mal de corruption et va mal
enfin bon la vie politique corse est une
catastrophe depuis depuis depuis assez
longtemps mais je dirais double les
indépendantistes ccc une 75 bon enfin
avec les coups d'éclat etc
c'est à leiria à leiria la cave ses
terres a six magazines et d'organismes
unis mais vous avez raison je pense que
c'est aussi les autonomistes
indépendantistes nationaliste c'est pas
un bon mot nationalistes patriotes
d'accord nationaliste je fasse je n'aime
pas cela prenne une place vide cette vie
politique corse clanique où on voyait
des des choses assez hallucinante qui
pour un continental un pin's août que
que je suis enfin et était assez
incroyable envoyé quand même la droite
traditionnelle s'allier parfois avec le
parti communiste face à face au parti
radical de gauche parti radical de
gauche qui faisait cavalier seul et qui
remportait des élections c'était
j'avais bien vu fracasser côté le renard
argenté rocca serra père et fils donc
c'est vraiment une terre comme comme lui
les indépendantistes aime à le dire
notre terre déjà c'est assez
insupportable notre terre à des terres à
nous tous et elle n'est pas encore ce
simplement c'est vraiment le c'est une
île tellement belle mais qui est
tellement aussi intéressante et
intrigante à étudier leur servait je
pense que nous ne sommes qu'au début
alors je sais pas je pensais au scénario
belge impôts scénario flamand vous savez
les les indépendantistes flamands les
autonomistes flamands sont parvenus au
pouvoir fédéral en belgique
en adoptant justement ce discours en
disant liminaire mais ce qui se passe en
belgique aujourd'hui c'est que avec le
maire d'anvers bart de wever qui est en
réalité le l'un des vrais dirigeants
fédéraux c'est c'est un détricotage du
fédéralisme belge avec eux avec une
tomine autonomisation ddd province de
plus en plus forte
on en est on n'est pas la belgique mais
mais je pense que c'est un scénario bien
plus subtile et vous le disiez plus
nombreux bien plus intelligent il y est
toujours et d'ailleurs y aurait une
histoire corse des relations justement
parce que est aussi toujours eu des
négociations du pouvoir des ministres de
l'intérieur successifs avec les
indépendantistes avec ses à l'époque
enfin bien sûr mais on jouera dialogue
la police souvent la gendarmerie
connaissait connaissait assez souvent
l'identité des encagoulés
on savait qu'ils s'étaient tout le monde
les connaissait re voilà les caméras
étaient convoqués se maquille nuitamment
pour ses conférences de presse assez
surréaliste enfin ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas quand même que du folklore on en
sourit mais gênant il n'ya pas qu'eux
les morts il y en a encore une ride et
une nuits bleues violente des choses est
ce que il ya comme ça alors il ya les
corses travail et la bretagne il ya le
pays basque pourquoi pas l'île de ré
patrice en 1968 il ya 2,2 rétais qui ont
proclamé l'indépendance de l'île de ré
je le signale en tant que charentais
maritimes et bien oui bon c'est alan
stephen harper puis c'est bon il ya eu
un il ya eu quand même eu un mort au
château de versailles revendiquée par
les par les autonomistes bretons une
bombe placée au château de versailles
est un os du parlement devant parlement
de bretagne rêve c'est indélicat
il ya eu un pylône edf qui a été
plastiquée dans les années 70 qui
pourrait demander
il reste les écoles diwan un nom breton
louis qui ont réclamé un statut officiel
et la possibilité contracté avec l'état
heureusement ça a été refusé
absolument heureusement mais il ya eu
une tendance en europe enfin de la
catalogne
enfin il ya les cosses il ya une
tendance à un certain nombre de régions
qui disent pourquoi pas aller de la
région à l'europe directement en fin
août sans passer par la case nation quel
état oui c'est dommage parce que les
règles de l'union européenne juste votre
script réel voilà c'était leur est
propre de la catalogne et we need
proclamé l'indépendance il n'était plus
la plupart de l'europe bien plus de
monnaies les plus grands shows et les
corses
on va voir le 21e tour la catalogne
du vote mais en france on a peut-être un
problème de structure territoriale est
ce qu'on voulait leur connaissance un
peu ce que la décentralisation est assez
forte comme on le lit ou pas justement
en france ce qu'elle est est-ce qu'on
est est-ce qu'on est encore est-ce qu'on
est un pays vraiment décentralisée ou
pas aujourd'hui on a une problématique
en france c'est que nous avons beaucoup
de millefeuille enfin nous avons un mot
et feuilles assez impressionnant et ce
millefeuille nous mêmes les élus on a
quand même du mal aujourd'hui à trouver
n'obtient sur nos compétences partagées
dont compétences obligatoires facilité
complexe et très complet très difficile
donc je je je pense que tant qu'on
n'aura pas eu le courage de mettre en
place une vraie réforme territoriale de
façon à ce qu'on redonne bien sûr je
dirais pas forcément une pyramide
parce que la centralisation est quand
même assez inquiétante faire attention
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu
ce que l'on ressent décentralisation
dans les faits on n'est pas encore le
détail très centralisé l'ajustement se
met en place une centralité nous
inquiète beaucoup au niveau des
territoires
en même temps comme les structurations
je lui disais territoriales ne sont pas
tout à fait bien structuré puisque
maintenant on commence on à la région
ile de france mais on parle maintenant
pourquoi pas d'une création d'une
métropole
parce que le grand paris aujourd'hui en
face désolidarise la grande banlieue de
la petite banlieue donc tout ça fait que
il ya beaucoup d'interrogations sur
jusqu'où on peut aller dans
l'application de nos compétences et puis
dans notre développement
donc si je pense que ça peut créer aussi
les interrogations par rapport est
pourquoi on devrait accepter tout cela
il ne pas aller directement à l'europe
pour pouvoir continuer à donner ce genre
de
imaginez je pense que c'est une théorie
qui soutient des régions à l'europe
tout se tient à partir du moment où il
ya des cohérence par rapport à
l'organisation de qui fait quoi
ouais aujourd'hui c'est compliqué je
peux vous dire que entre la région ile
de france les départements qui sont en
place et je peux vous en parler
les intercommunalités et les lilas je
peux vous dire c'est compliqué alors
vous êtes au centre
qu'est-ce que vous êtes dans un petit
département dans la terre communauté et
maire mais puisqu'on va parler de fusion
un moment entre les yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine où on en est on en est on
en est que nous avons fusionné puisqu'en
juin nous avons voté la fusion entre les
deux départements et les gars accès on a
pris les devants on va dire oui c'est un
peu comme banal comme comme les corses
et ronaldo
et puis en même temps ça fait ça et puis
en même temps
et en même temps on attend que le
conseil d'état puisse nous donner son
accord
ce qui n'est pas forcément facile c'est
pas le ressenti que nous avons à
l'accord de conseils des tories non mais
je crois que la selva 2015 qui prévoyait
que la fusion était possible de la loi
est déjà voté par avance mais il me
semble que le gouvernement a son mot à
dire et au conseil d'état on verra mais
je crois que c'est assez mal parti au
regard de la physionomie de ces deux
départements qui sont pas deux
départements quand même tout à fait
comme une session de quand même c'est
peut-être les deux départements les plus
riches de fruits simple routine enfin je
crois
[Musique]
soixante dix huit noms bien sûr mais
mais en même temps en même temps c'est
pour ça qu'il ya une réflexion
aujourd'hui sur cette métropole qui nous
paraît serait pas créé assez cohérente
par rapport à l'île de france
et voilà donc on est vraiment dans des
interrogations de gouvernance et
d'éthique
c'est extrêmement intéressant parce que
c'était pas de vous avez raison de
rappeler le
le droit la loi l'avis du conseil d'état
qui est important mais est ce qu'on
n'est pas dans un monde enfin en 2017 on
aime ou des gens
assez sérieux pourrait se dire si on
était ensemble ça serait mieux et est ce
que on a toujours besoin de l'aval de
l'état
est ce que parce que voilà ce que la
décision qui se prend au niveau des
citoyens au niveau de la dette justement
au niveau décentralisé n'est pas forte
politiquement en tout cas est ce que ce
serait pas bien ou mieux si on était
ensemble le l'état nation tel qu'il
s'est construit chez nous c'est
précisément cela fait dix ans qu'on est
ensemble on forme une communauté
communauté de citoyens car un citoyen en
vaut un autre
je trouve que c'est déjà pas mal ça
alors pardonnez moi de jouer un peu la
coban servi moi je fais une telle
culture de l'état en france que ça
ferait il me semble difficile de
basculer vers un modèle espagnol
j'en sais rien enfin c'est ça me semble
pas pas envisageable du moins tout de
suite et alors la décentralisation on la
conçoit quand même
donald est de nature administrative et
c'est là la différence majeure avec les
communautés autonomes c'est que il ya
décentralisation en fin politique où on
a attribué aux régions une compétence et
les compétences de faire la loi en
italie c'est la même chose l'état une
compétence subsidiaire sont les régions
qui en principe doivent doivent ce qui
n'est pas notre histoire ce qui n'est
pas notre culture on cite souvent
l'allemagne n'avons pas la même histoire
non plus il ya quand même cette question
au delà de l'égalité 2-2 d'une culture
de l'indivisibilité alors qu'ils qui
correspond pas à ce qu'on dit calais
c'est pas le territoire qui est
indivisible puisque des parties du
territoire français peuvent prendre leur
indépendance les comores 75
nouvelle calédonie et sur un processus
d'indépendance aussi c'est
l'indivisibilité de la souveraineté
on forme un peuple ça n'est quand même
pas rien et les yvelines et le 98 groupe
l'avenir du limousin
dans le limousin a fait passer ses
vacances et la région ce que vous les
rappeler stéphane c'est que les
collectivités territoriales ne peuvent
faire que ce que l'état veut bien
qu'elle fasse puisque ne sont pas
souverains les discours quelle serait
l'alternative de verre que les algues
main de fer que les départements fin que
les collectivités territoriales d'une
manière générale pourrait prendre de
leur propre initiative un certain nombre
de décisions mais ça serait leur
reconnaître une totale souveraineté si
c'était le cas la corse pourrait si elle
le souhaitait accéder à l'indépendance
au nom d'une initiative locale puisque
le mouvement indépendant des
nationalistes et majoritaire dans l'île
et pourtant sur ce terrain la majorité
en tous cas à paris on parle beaucoup
enfin on a des accents jacobins très
fort pour dire que les corses feront
tout ce qu'ils veulent mais dans le
respect de ce que l'état français aura
décidé donc il est bien que l'état garde
la main et si ensuite l'état souhaite
donner plus de liberté ou moins de
liberté c'est une chose mais il faut
quand même que les choses se fassent
dans six pire quand même deux fois s'est
passé pas une insulte aux morts
mais il faut se méfier aussi parce que
au four en angleterre la manière dont la
loi est fabriqué en france laisse une
place extrêmement importante à la voix
des élus locaux
alors pendant longtemps grâce au cumul
des mandats on imagine assez peu assez
mal l'influencé énorme des élus locaux
dans la dans la confection de la loi
nationale les ce que je voudrais appeler
des interférences entre les différents
intérêts les intérêts l'hôtel à bain d
art et la terreur
oui de devoir les élus locaux comme une
forme de contre prévoir de ce qui n'est
pas faux politiquement d'ailleurs et
aujourd'hui on sait très bien que rien
de majeur ne se fait en france sans
globalement l'assentiment je pense à
essentiellement à l'association des
maires de france qui est un et un pour
le coup un contre pouvoir mais
considérable une force considérable
donc il faut aussi que les élus locaux
s'interrogent sur ce qu'ils sont prêts
eux aussi et vous parliez de la
simplification c'est vrai que si fou il
va falloir qu'on y arrive un jour ou
l'autre mais ça suppose pour les pour
nombre d'élus locaux d'abandonner leur
mandat
donc ça c'est pas facile mais vous savez
la majorité des élus que l'on a avec qui
je travaille sont tout à fait conscients
que de toute façon il ya trop d'élus ne
serait ce que sur la strate communal par
exemple quand vous aviez nord on
pourrait déjà regroupé certaines
communes d'ailleurs ça se fête
voilà à l'intérieur des agglos ça se
fait l'écho mx
mais même au sein d'un conseil municipal
il ya trop de conseillers sur plaisir 39
conseillers vous montez innus avec 39
personnes
en vérité les volcans et une 32 me en
vérité je vous le dis
quinze personnes suffirait amplement
amplement le groupe des adjoints et puis
quelques élus pour les commissions en
tant que conseillers municipaux ça
suffirait amplement donc déjà là dessus
durée du travail à faire si vous prenez
toutes les strates qualités mentales
c'est la même chose donc et ça je peux
vous dire qu'en règle générale les élus
sont plutôt d'accord pour cette
simplification déjà ce niveau là les
coordonnées - les grands élus entre
guillemets sont pas les mêmes c'est pas
le même monde et ça valait mieux qu'on
entend le plus bien sûr et c'est ce qui
donne l'image est la plus belle que si
on la voit qui est problématique pour
nous parfois le château chaud et parfois
dessus il c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
on a souvent l'impression justement que
ce qui bloque dans la réforme de ces
strates qui s'ajoutent les unes aux
autres
c'est ben c'est le le pouvoir chacun
c'est à dire que chacun tient à sa
fonction et que c'est très compliqué à
réformer la main si vous dites que déjà
des élus serait plutôt favorable à ça
c'est quand même important sur le nombre
parce que je suis sans voix
gérer une équipe c'est pas simple je
veux dire surtout qu'aujourd'hui vous
avez pu le constater on n'est plus
derrière un seul homme un comme c'était
avant
aujourd'hui une espèce de mouvement même
en interne c'est un petit peu ce qui se
passe au niveau national d'ailleurs
nationale enfin peu à droite on prend un
peu à gauche c'est un bon là c'est un
peu pareil dans les équipes même si vous
montez votre équipe
c'est pas sûr qu'au bout de trois ans
vous voyez pas les perditions détention
c'est pas ça je veux pas leur donner
suffisamment de choses c'est pas du tout
la même chose
et j'essaye pourtant enfin j'essaie je
pense que mes collègues font de même
mais et on essaie véritablement de faire
une
un partage d'informations leaf c'est
quand on dit conseiller municipal déjà
la terminologie est erronée il ne
conseille rien du tout il accompagne je
dirais quelque chose qui se met en place
bien sûr avec eux dans le sens d'une
organisation mais rien que ça alors
quand vous arrivez de conseiller
municipal et vous avez une envie sait
faire plein de choses et on vous dit non
tu conseiller municipal tu peux pas
aller donner les ordres dire
tu n'as pas de délégation véritablement
vous fait des frustrés
donc il vaut mieux avoir quinze mois
véritablement avec des vrais délégation
dans ce cas là c'est plus du tout la
même chose
comment serait déjà par sa au niveau
d'une réforme je peux vous dire qu'on
ferait déjà des sacrées économies on
serait plus efficace voulez parler de
l'éducation un petit peu la forme ce
diktat comme l'indiqué autour de la
dictée à la france 34e au niveau de
lecture pratiquement mais sur cinq ans
la russie et les russes les locaux c'est
c'est assez intéressant parce qu'à
chaque fois qu'il transporte lequel
seront dix à chaque année la france
régresse et en même temps les
enseignants voulaient faire les
responsables de l'enseignement ou les
pédagogues 10 mais non le niveau monte
plus tôt oui ça c'est déjà que c'est ce
qu'on a dit pour le nom pour les
classements mathématiques nous on dit ça
on est soit 10 20 on est nul en maths en
france mais on allait plus on arrive à
l'école d'excellents matic la brillante
au c'est vrai on peut l'affirmer qui
médecin donc voila voila il faut pas
confondre le niveau général
et puis oui
vérité c'est pareil en français en
orthographe
après je me suis quand même une très
bonne idée de la part de blanc caire on
ne comprend pas bien pourquoi ça n'a pas
été fait jusqu'à présent en fin de leur
faire des dictées faisable pareil engin
du gîte l évidence je ne savais pas que
la dictée ne faisait plus aux femmes et
enfants cdc d'indiscrétions de gens
saignants il peut ne pas le faire donc
ceci dit moi je suis trouvée distinction
entre la ligne la lecture et l'écriture
et en os dit qu'un problème de lecture
et en répandant et les cris de joie mais
d'abord je veux dire alors juste et que
parce qu'on le voit à l'université les
bacheliers qui arrivent ont des
problèmes énormes en attendant d'autres
amer donc je vis tout à fait souhaitable
qu'ils puissent faire des dictées mais
ça répond pas au problème de la lecture
lecture ou juste parce qu'ils ont des
problèmes de compréhension sur l'analyse
d'un texte sur la manière de penser de
l'argumenter et je pense que il faut
aussi trouver une solution à ce problème
et il faisait pas par exemple de
différence quand le sujet était une
chose ou une personne enfin c'est leur
posait pas de poser et là c'est vraiment
de la lecture en effet plus que de plus
que de l'orthographe on sait pas c'est
pas ça passe juste l'orthographe rue
mais il faut pouvoir édicter au sens le
plus large du terme c'est à dire que en
maîtrisant leur taux grimper la dictée
ou quand on comprend quand même quelques
règles qui permettent de lire après plus
facilement
puis après c'est l'oeuf et la poule
c'est vrai qu'une fois qu'on a commencé
à un peu savoir lire en photographie des
mots on est capable de musique
marc cécillon si on l'y a priori on
aimait réponse qu'on libre
on a repéré trop tard vous offre le
livre si vous trouvez que trouver la
fécafoot
mais non si l'on essayé d'être aussi
qu'ils ont déjà tant que ça marche pas
mon truc
alors
jean baptiste nous habille était très
intéressé par un sujet qui a fait la une
du nouvel obs podologue sont imminents
il ya quelques il ya quelques jours
c'était faut-il déboulonner les statues
de l'histoire parce que colbert on ordre
17,1 au grand homme un grand homme en
fait c'est le sait le père du code noir
qui était voilà l'origine de l'esclavagé
napoléon auteurs de crimes contre
l'humanité ferry on avait déjà dit ça
sur le colonialisme et c est ce que il
faut dire ce qui est c'est le problème
est ce qu'il faudra compter un roman
national
est-ce qu'il faut prendre une seule un
sac des aspects de ces grandes figures
historiques ou est-ce qu'il faut il faut
apprendre aux élèves la réalité ce
qu'ils étaient vraiment bons mais ça le
question c'est ça je pense que le sujet
c'est plutôt de déboulonner en fait les
idées reçues qu'on peut se faire sur un
personnage historique et donc
effectivement de voir le personnage dans
toute sa complexité de le récit de se
situer dans son contexte et donc c'est
vrai que lorsqu'on attribue parfois tel
ou tel personnage tel ou tel crime
bon c'est parfois un peu caricatural
parce que lorsqu'on peut moi même me
présentais personnage c'est à autre
chose que je vais penser donc
effectivement je pense qu'il faut
fabriquer colbert donc cette idée de
deux plaques et une étiquette sur un
personnage et de le réduire à ça c'est
plus tout ça qui est regrettable et qui
est une mère n'ose
porte d'entrée aussi dans la
compréhension et dans la l'idée qu'on se
fait de l'histoire comme science mais ce
qu'on n'a pas aussi une tendance au
comptant ont fait ça à juger des
comportements passés avec d'autres yeux
d'aujourd'hui
oui mais c'est le faire des pôles
d'activité le enfin cesser un peu
d'humilité que diable on va enfin en
effet porter un regard contemporain sur
ce qui s'est passé dans notre histoire
enfin c'est une c'est un révisionnisme
qui est insupportable et c'est jean
baptiste à raison laissons l'histoire
aux historiens même si alors chacun doit
se l'approprier mais l'histoire c'est
une science qui se construit dans le
débat mais dans le débat scientifique
stade dans le débat argumenté
c'est ce qui se passe là enfin moi me me
laisse à dire que ça nous montre quand
même une chose intéressante c'est on
voit la façon dont l'histoire se fait et
on voit que ce récit national qui est à
mon avis indispensable n'a pas laissé de
place à certains à certains individus
alors à certaines communautés mais j'ai
du mal à dire cela il ya qu une seule
communautaire de république ce sont les
citoyens
mais cela dit alors c'est je trouve ça
mais mais il recevable raison enfin
empressons nous de détruire et de raser
le château de versailles qui a abrité un
despote insupportable et alors à
déboulonner les statues mais qu'ils
aient failli rester plus personne non
mais ce qu'on peut pas détruisons le
pantin mais qui abrite sur voltaire
voltaire qui étaient scandaleusement
l'or qui a été qu'ils étaient favorables
au code noir qui n'a rien fait qui n'a
rien dit alors jules-ferry oui au à ce
moment là je le fais rien peut-être un
peu plus coupable parce que il y avait
quelqu'un comme clemenceau par exemple
qui avait déjà souligné dans ce deal
assez fort que l'esclave h c'était pas
bien
le parti s'était pas bien mais mais il y
avait des abus et qui avait des abus
mais ceci n'est jules ferry ce n'est pas
que cela non plus et donc je jean
baptiste est née son papa de plaisir
d'apercevoir escaut parce que ce qu'il
reproche ces gens là qui voudrait un peu
de déboulonner ccsn justement c'est de
dire ouf on a une vision univoque ses
personnages et on peut entrer dans le
débat
bien sûr on débat est ouvert mais ce
n'est pas d'hier il ya ça de bien mais
non bien sûr et je le trouve que vous
voyez c'est c'est prendre l'argument
l'argument contesté à rebours et et
proposer une solution qui finalement
vont pas mieux
c'est à dire non mais colbert c'était un
immonde esclavagiste d'accord mais
c'était pas que ça non plus en fait
c'était aussi un homme ça a été un
ministre
l'argentier un grand argentier c'est
vrai qu'il est à l'origine des
fondateurs de l'état de la construction
moderne de l'état en france mais je suis
d'accord il n'était pas que ça non plus
les deux la marine et de maryse
l'ordonance de colbert à l'ordonnancé
suivra bien sûr qu est ce que le fait
d'enlever les statuts va enlever
je dirais le personnage en tant que tel
et la connaissance que londres est pas
du tout je veux dire si très anecdotique
si grave de l'est de le dire de
l'évoquer mais je trouve que si une
statue en soit c'est pas quelque chose
qui qui va nous enlever là je dirais
voilà la critique que nous pourrions
avoir
et les compliments que nous pourrions y
apporter par rapport à leurs actions ça
revient de manière récurrente la
révision des paroles de la marseillaise
mais cet égard il est l'heure mais c'est
un champ de guerre serre chaude c'est
pas une berceuse son chien de la nature
est scellé qu'est ce que ces grands
vidange dans le monde de bisounours on
en 2001 je m'en viens on pourrait penser
qu'elle en effet elle été créée l'été
craignent des faibles histoire où il ya
on est et où la france était en guerre
on pourrait penser que le pôle pour et
évolue et pourquoi pas de secret c'est
sacré on touche pas que les rh d'hitler
a parait-il était absolument adorable
avec son berger allemand donc voilà
qu'est ce qu'on ferait louis laquelle il
a dû dire je la fait beau le soleil
fascistes ont travaillé bon fassions
cela n'a pas de sens voyez quand on
raisonne comme ça ce n'est pas tout
c'était si c'etait tres et elle avait
publié en fin et on a payé à quelques
essais au journal dont qu'elle
rencontrait effet souvent il clair et
c'était très amusant les rencontres avec
qui elle avait dit un jour pourquoi vous
vous mariez pas il avait dit parce que
c'est une marianne eux
je voulais parler
une la une de l'express edwy plenel bien
c'est la vie c'est notre job qui le
divise la france
l'ami de jean fabre je ne suis pas sûr
que il divise vraiment la france mais
enfin bon ça reste qu'un peu une tempête
dans un verre d'eau mais bon je pense
que la majorité des gens qui se sait
fondera la devant la la perte de la
disparition de johnny hallyday sont
assez peu courant ne connaissent même
pas edwy plenel s'en contrefoutent et je
pense qu'ils ont a ses raisons mais
enfin c'est ok non mais c'est après
voilà que c'est assez pitoyable la
question on avait de la joie nié les
faits de la polémique avec avec charlie
sur les desseins de charlie et sur sa
défense n'est sur sa défense des
musulmans allah
il ya un portrait qui est pas mal dans
l'express ou quelqu'un dit au fond il a
fait des musulmans les sorts de damnés
de la terre c'est à dire qu'il cherche
toujours une cause à défendre
il l'a trouvé celle là ce serait oui
c'est sa mêlée les rejeter les damnés de
la terre pour qu'il faut se battre et
c'est vrai que ça lave globe les
jugements qu'il a pu se dire je pense
qu'il est assez enfin maintenant est
tombée dans un champ de caricature
permanente
je sais même pas ce qu'ils quelqu'un va
continuer avait envie de débattre avec
lui puisque je comprends même pas un mot
alors dire je sais pas si je sais pas il
faudrait je pense que oui aujourd'hui je
pense que ça fait probablement plus
vendre charlie hebdo parce que beaucoup
jacques servier qui s'était détaché de
charlie hebdo est quand même très
honnêtement pas toujours un bon journal
m il est même assez peu souvent bon
journal honnêtement mais là c'est vrai
que plus plenel attaque londubat
finalement chez les blues peut-être pas
si mal enfin du coup par la jolie qui
fait qu'ils font de génération point s
vous comprenez sa démarche par exemple
parce qu'il est non mais non c est ce
que la vraie question par dont celle ci
dans la génération qui dans les gêner
dans une dernière action non mais est ce
que vous n'avez pas l'impression
justement que ces quelques par exemple
il est rêve de faire une alliance pour
l'europe avec varrault factice est-ce
que c'est pas quelqu'un qui se complaît
totalement dans l'opposition terriens ou
qu'un aucune envie de pouvoir et c'est
est-ce que c'est pas un problème un peu
preuve d'un certain nombre d'hommes
politiques c'est peut-être parce qu'il
est assez clairvoyant aussi sur cette
possibilité
dont l'opposition visiblement que avec
un pouvoir bien que oui c'est ce que
c'est ça mais ils pourraient revoir pour
y avoir des alternatives c'est vrai que
yahia il ya un certain nombre de gens
qui se complaisent référé la réunion
salek varoufakis qui n'est même pas
majoritaires alors que vous avez un type
comme si price qui se bat comme un fou
pour pour la grèce c'est quand même
bizarre c'est quand même étrange me
semble-t-il ce génération point s ce
rappel à l'écriture inclusive toile
allemande est totalement déprimé nantes
il est allé au tapis non mais le
précédent non son mouvement était déjà
pris et anouar sadate voit maintenant
cette génération pointe
on se demande quelle va être la
prochaine blague doit avoir un mode coop
dernière lui qu'il est en tout cas c'est
en dehors du parti socialiste oui oui on
s'en doutait un peu quand même parce que
visiblement il n'en veulent plus mais
puis il n'existe plus parti socialiste
fille et moi mais je vous verrai où le
parti socialiste aujourd'hui mais toute
façon à rien je dirais à un élu quel
qu'il soit de quelque bord qu'ils soient
à un moment donné quand il disparaît de
dire il faut recréer quelque chose et
vous créez comment dans l'opposition
vous recréez en trouvant oui j'en ai on
va voir une opération cannes il ya des
oppositions qui peuvent avoir la volonté
de prendre le pouvoir appuyer des
positions qui ont aussi la volonté de
rester dans l'opposition il me semble je
ne sais pas lutter
il me semble qu'ils aient fait plutôt
pâle seven c4 l'opposition plurielle
puisqu'il emploie le oui est ce que tu
réponds personnellement il ya des grands
une dans une position qu une opposition
et bars de crohn et pardon c'est une
opposition chronique
oui c'est ça je vous remercie d'avoir
participé à cette édition
merci merci à tous les quatre on se
retrouve très vite pour un nouveau
numéro de partout si vous êtes d'accord
[Musique]